hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I wanted
to go over a game from the Gibraltar
Masters Tournament that I believe is
wrapping up at the time of filming this
is a game between two very strong
players those players are chakra are mom
and jar of and Anna Musa Chuck of course
Anna muzie tricks sister is actually
going to be playing in the Karin's Cup
Anna herself I believe is tied up in
Gibraltar as we'll see from this game
this is actually a very interesting game
it shows the depth of opening prep that
these players actually go to and the
advantages when one player actually gets
a little bit caught so let's see what
happens
shock started with Knight f3 and I
responded with C 5 c4 knight c6 Knight
c3 Knight f6 both players developing
very important we see III and this is
where the CIMMYT the symmetry was broken
black can respond with a six if she so
desired
instead she played e5 taking a more
aggressive approach to controlling the
center unfortunately since white gets to
move first black cannot adequately
control d4 enough to prevent white from
playing it so white plays d4 anyways and
the main line here goes C takes d4 he
takes d4 followed by e4 what Anna
decided to do was very very similar she
just played efore immediately the
response to this is Knight e5 for shock
and it simply develops with g6 keeping
this tension in the center for a little
bit longer and here shock plays a move
that is surprising to my eyes but
actually he's played it before so
hopefully it wasn't too surprising to
Anna
of course these players go very very
deep excitement a lot of their opponents
games for each round here in this move
is g4 and this moves pretty interesting
sometimes when you play g4 it's to
launch a devastating attack on the Kings
side sometimes when you play g4 it's to
prevents a very simple move like
something like f5 later on
in this case shot plays g4 and I don't
think the idea for shock was actually to
try and break through on the kingside
right away I think he just wanted some
extra space and this is an idea we're
seeing a lot more often these days at
the top level players are not really
shying away from playing these
traditionally weakening moves like g4
just to get this extra space just to
make their opponent feel a little bit
more cramps and I think that's why it
shock played a cure and a response with
h6 preventing any g5 ideas shock simply
plays Bishop g2 let me see Bishop g7 now
shock simply plays h3 he defends his
pawn on g4 he takes the time out of his
day to make sure everything stays solid
and he's he's just ready to continue now
with development he's just gonna leave
this pawn on g4 for the foreseeable
future and here is where we actually
deviate from Shox previous games
historically this was played again shock
in a game from 2018 where he had the
white pieces against actually maxing the
Sheila Graf and Queen e7 I think is is
the best move that game continued with
b3 and in the game and the L plate C
takes d4 he takes d4 and Knight takes e5
D takes e5 and Queen takes e5 and here
shot game added upon in exchange for
some open lines and some pressure
against this black center and now you
really see how the white pawns have been
positioned such that this pawn on e4 is
going to be a little bit loose a little
bit isolated and I think this was
actually a pretty good way of playing
for mvl despite the fact that you did go
on to lose that game and the move that
anna played is actually a lot more
combative but i think it simply gives
white an edge she tried d5 immediately
breaking in the center trying to break
down all of these white pawns but then
we saw something similar to the game
with MVL happen but there were there
were some key differences which we're
gonna examine here shock actually just
captures on d5 we see Knight takes d5
and now Knight takes e4 is the point and
now it's it's actually black who has
gamed it upon
already early on we CC takes d4 he takes
d4 castles and castles and now that the
difference here I think is if you look
at the MDL game MVL got rid of this d4
pawn and was left with this eforp on and
white still had a little bit of an edge
despite the fact that he was down this
pawn the difference in this case is
white has this edge in activity and also
he's the one who's up the pawn so anna
is going to be scrambling to try and
regain this pawn while in the meantime
shot can focus solely on activating his
pieces not having to worry about
returning a gambit pawn and in the game
and actually made another mistake here I
think the best move would have been
something like Queen b6 really eyeing
this d4 pawn immediately trying to
regain it and this asks White's some
awkward questions in fact shock is going
to have to make some kind of concession
here option number one to deal with this
weakness is to play Bishop e3 but this
is actually just a terrible move black
will capture and capture he gets all of
the pawns so you can't defend this pawn
this should be threes like the only way
to really defend this pawn unless you
want to play like Knight f3 which
unveils the bishop or the one of his
real options which is Knight c5 but 9 c5
is in fact a concession because now
after Knight takes e5 you can't really
recapture so you'll see Bishop takes d5
and after knight c6 you're attacking
this pawn so white can now defend it but
after something like rook d8 or queen d8
black is in fact going to be regaining
this pawn in the center so Knight c5
doesn't really keep the the D pawn so
your only option to maintain the extra
pawn is to take this knight on c6 but
this change in structure is actually
pretty favorable for black this knight
on d5 is a lot more solid and you're
going to have permanent lasting pressure
against this d4 pawn and while white
should have an edge here thanks to the
extra material black what about a pretty
reasonable game instead though Anna
didn't play quite so quickly for
pressure against d4 instead playing rook
e8 trying to take off this Knight but
now in fact Jacques finds some very
clever tactics he plays rookie one here
and now after Knight takes e5 which was
the idea we simply see D takes e5 Anna
recaptures this pawn with rook takes e5
but now we actually see that the black
pieces are coordinated a little bit
awkwardly there's just some very very
annoying threats to deal with in the
position that you wouldn't necessarily
expect in the game shock played Bishop
e3 which is a very good move but in fact
it's not the best move the best move is
actually Bishop f4 taking advantage of
this pin to the black Queen and then the
very very natural rook e8 actually fails
to some very very fun tactics that I'd
like to show you guys so what happens if
you want to pause the video here to try
and find the winning tactic for white go
ahead now it's a fun one
of course the winning move everybody
sees it Queen takes d5 and now if black
recaptures is this piece we're simply
gonna play Knight f6 check and after
Bishop takes f6 do we take the Queen we
could but no first we take this extra
rook and take on on d5 and of course
black doesn't have to fall for this
tactic all the way but does highlight
how the black pieces are just
coordinated a little bit too awkwardly
so after Bishop f4 black would have to
play something like rookie 7 and now
Queen d2 would be a nice move just to
highlight that this this pawn is going
to be very very weak you can play
something like g5 but you're running
into some very annoying tactics like
Bishop d6 difficult stuff for black to
be sure instead though we saw Bishop e3
and here perhaps and I should have tried
to develop this Bishop a little bit
allow a move like Bishop d4 and simply
sacrifice this exchange in exchange for
the bishop pair and some threats to the
king of side Enix in instead of that
though we actually see rook e8 from Anna
now this tactic doesn't quite work
because this bishops in the way which is
why Bishop f4 might have been a little
bit more accurate instead though shock
finds another very nice tactic and that
tactic is Bishop takes h6 with the same
or a very similar idea you want to
distract this Bishop from the f6 square
and then capture on d5 and this is what
we see in the game black doesn't have to
fall for this of course so Anna instead
plays Bishop e6 but now the damage has
been done and shock is simply going to
be up a clean a pawn in this position so
Rick takes B to shock activates all of
his pieces with Rick d1 the Queen comes
out to h4 and now what do you do with an
extra pawn you make use of it passed
pawns must be pushed so we see a four a
five a six shock wastes no time and in
fact it's two extra pawns I should stay
with the H pawn missing for black as
well
riki seven is Anna's choice not the most
astute defense but it's a losing
position anyways Queen C 5 is shocks
response giving this pawn back but in
exchange we see some devastating threats
land to land around this black King
Knight g5 actually interferes with the
Queen and makes up threat to the rook
let's see wreck a2 was Anna's response
to this of course now taking would be a
mistake due to checkmate instead though
simply rook f1 renewing the threat to
the rook King g7 defending now Queen e5
check King comes back to g8 and Queen f6
and this is where Anna actually decided
to resign there's simply too many
threats around this black King black
can't can't handle it
once again the circus attacked the only
way to really deal with it is to play
rook a7 but now we simply have takes
takes Knight takes and in the Queen will
fall and this is why if black threw in
the towel here nothing to be done a very
impressive game actually from shocked
mom and ER of proving once again why he
has maintained his position clear it
clearly above 2700 and usually in the
top 10 shock a world-class player
showing how opening prep can get it done
thank you very much for joining me in
this week's episode of game review and I
will see you in the next episode